hillary says democrats trap
is pushing woke crap
so the dams have become so dense that
even she's making sense
[Laughter]
in a new interview hillary clinton the
first lady of second place
was that
terrible
red meat applause
was asked why dems seem to be going out
of their way to lose elections by
focusing on causes that only affect a
small fraction of voters funny asking
hillary how to win elections is like
asking france how to win wars
but she seemed to admit the interview
was right chasing woke issues noting
quote look the most important thing is
to win the next election the alternative
is so frightening that whatever does not
help you win should not be a priority
meaning it's not like she's against
wokesters she just knows most americans
are suddenly there are more deplorables
than ever she singled out the
progressive push to defund the police
adding you need accountability
accountable measures but you also need
policing it doesn't even pass the common
sense politics test not to believe that
end quote
so hillary knows police are the best way
to control criminals and perverts
especially the ones that share a house
with you
walk right into that
of course all this sober talk from
clinton is because she knows in december
the dems are gonna get flattened like a
beach chair and bryant stelter's
backyard
but van jones made the point much
clearer on cnn thursday much to the
blank stares of the hosts
we are in danger of becoming a party of
the very high and the very low you've
got people who are very well educated
and very well off those people talk
funny latinx i've never met a latinx
i've never met a bipoc i've never met
you know all these this weird stuff that
these highly educated people say it's
bizarre and then the people who are very
low down on the economic ladder need a
bunch of stuff you wind up over
promising oh we're going to give you
reparations to people at the bottom of
the economic ladder talking weird to
appeal to people the topic that are in
the work class walks away from you hmm
incredible first hillary and now cnn
making sense what's next joe biden
winning the tour de france
[Laughter]
it's funny
because he can't ride a bike you get
that
cat
you get it i get it you can't ride a
bike
a tour de france is a bike competition
yes yes i i do know that also i am joke
splaining to show you what a sexist male
might do and it's disgusting what are
your thoughts on this up topic pat
it's not even an original take because
it is so obvious
uh i think it's interesting that we're
you know we are hearing from hillary
again
uh because ad
you know to all that that we don't ever
see joe biden we rarely see joe biden
and then add to that every time we do
see joe biden it becomes apparent why we
don't see him more often
i don't think anyone should be involved
in culture like cultural issues that's
in the government i don't think we need
like pro-drag queen legislation i also
don't think we need anti-drag queen
legislation i don't think it's a top
issue for anyone especially when so many
people for some yes
but i think people are facing real
serious problems now and they'd like to
see somebody give that at some point
what do you make of that
caitlyn
the idea that like it's kind of like
that hierarchy of needs yeah this is uh
you know the democrats are in trouble
when they're taking how to win elections
advice from hillary clinton yeah yeah
you know you know they got problems in
van jones yeah but
um
i have to say something i think she's uh
her statement about not using like trans
issues and stuff to try to win elections
and all that sort of stuff i'm going to
say this i've never said it before in my
life right here on national television
are you ready yeah
hillary clinton was right
never said never have said that before
yeah but she's absolutely right van
jones um interesting quick story about
him years ago i did a um a dinner for
mtv
and um
uh at uh katy perry's house
and they had a whole group of
celebrities and i walk in and van jones
is there i said oh my god i'm getting
set up
i got all these hollywood people me the
conservative republican yeah and van
jones i said i'm dead yeah
i have to admit out of everybody in that
room the only person i could get along
with was van gaal he's got a great
reputation he was like the sanest person
there kt what do you make of this whole
business okay so i've got a little
different take i ran against hillary in
2006 for the senate um from new york and
she's very tricky yes so if you kind of
dissect what she's saying she said
pretend this she is what yeah she tend
to be like this and then get in
reasonable i'm really reasonable i mean
she's now looking like the adult in the
room and everybody's talking about the
democrats have no bench right i mean aoc
is going to run for president i mean
come on they have nobody republicans
have 20 people who would make great
presidents i think what she's doing is
putting the seed in say well i'm not
interested in running but joe biden i'm
sure he's going to be the candidate in
2024. he's not going to be the candidate
in 2024. we all know that but so who
looks like they're reasonable
she's telling you to adopt a public
persona and then when you get in you can
then be yourself what are those little
things remember those things used to
advertise do you put your feet on when
you're on the toilet oh body parts
they don't have a bench they have a
squatty potty
i had to actually ask for the punchline
i had to ask for the punch line kt it
was a pretty sophisticated argument it
is but no you're right you're right you
just you clicked my brain i was like
going yeah that's possible she's kind of
like saying and then no another
reporters jimmy asked her about uh like
the fact that she originated the russian
collusion hoax that that's like not even
mentioned yeah they they never they
never ever ever touched that but kt is
right she is angling to run again
hillary clinton is like
a political yeah
she's actually she will never stories
she will never stop running inevitably
ever she will never stop running someday
trump rallies will be chanting help her
up
[Applause]
there's an old adage that the presidency
is a disease that's only curable by
death meaning if you want to run for
want to be the president bad enough yeah
that's all you ever want to do is keep
on running so that's what it is she
keeps trying to stipulate me
on to some extent but i actually just
think she wants to be president she
thinks it's her birthright and that's
why she said the quiet part out loud
let's focus on what wins election she's
admitting don't worry about helping
people don't worry about advancing
causes you care about let's just get in
that's why we're all making these
analogies about taking political advice
from hillary it's really like taking
marriage advice from oj but the reason
the reason that doesn't hold up is o.j
was accused of fewer murders that's the
only thing
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else